How the Phrase Red Herring Came to Mean Something
That is Misleading
Meaning a distraction or false trail, the
expression “red herring” has been relatively
commonly used for the last two centuries,
and its origins do, in fact, begin with a
rust-colored fish.
However, until quite recently, the accepted
origins of red herring were themselves a false
trail.
The literal sense of a red herring dates to
at least 1250 AD when Walter of Bibbesworth
wrote in The Treatise, “He etep no ffyssh
But Heryng red.”
A product of the process used to preserve
the fish into a kipper, the herring is cured
in salt brine and then smoked for up to 10
days.
If enough brine is used, the fish turns a
red, coppery color with a rather strong smell.
Capable of being stored for long periods of
time, this dried kipper was inedible until
after it was first soaked in water to remove
the salt, and then it could be warmed and
eaten.
A staple in English society, particularly
among the poor, there would have been a fair
amount of tough, dried red herring hanging
about.
And, given that they had a strong smell, it
makes sense that their aroma would attract
animals.
Accordingly, in 1697, Nicholas Cox described
just such a use in The Gentleman’s Recreation,
where a red herring was supposedly dragged
along a route to get a young puppy to learn
to follow a trail.
Others expounded upon Cox’s idea and said
that later in the training, while following
a fox or badger, a red herring would be dragged
perpendicular across the animal’s path to
confuse the dog at first, but ultimately lead
to a dog that could stick to an original scent
as opposed to a compelling, intervening scent.
This explanation was, for many years, accepted
as the origin of using red herring to mean
a false trail.
But, as previously noted, this explanation
is actually a red herring as Cox’s initial
description was based on mistranslation of
a book on horse training by Gerland Langbaine
(also published in 1697).
In the book, Langbaine recommended using a
dead cat or fox for dogs to track and horses
to in turn be trained to follow, with the
red herring used to draw the dogs if cat or
fox was not available.
In this case, there was no deception happening,
as would later be stated to support the notion
that this is where the expression came from,
and it wasn’t the dogs being trained, as
Cox would himself state.
This red herring was only revealed recently,
in a pair of articles published in Comments
on Etymology in 2008, along with what is now
accepted as the actual origin of our use of
the phrase red herring.
In the early part of the 19th century, journalist
and rabble-rouser William Cobbett used his
publication Weekly Political Register to decry
the English political establishment.
In one story written on February 14, 1807,
while illustrating the gullibility of his
fellow members of the press, Cobbett described
the following use of a red herring, ostensibly
from his childhood, though thought to be a
fictional account:
When I was a boy, we used, in order to draw
oft’ the harriers from the trail of a hare
that we had set down as our own private property,
get to her haunt early in the morning, and
drag a red-herring, tied to a string, four
or five miles over hedges and ditches, across
fields and through coppices, till we got to
a point, whence we were pretty sure the hunters
would not return to the spot where they had
thrown off; and, though I would, by no means,
be understood, as comparing the editors and
proprietors of the London daily press to animals
half so sagacious and so faithful as hounds,
I cannot help thinking, that, in the case
to which we are referring, they must have
been misled, at first, by some political deceiver.
However, while Cobbett seems to have popularized
the figurative sense of a red herring being
a false trail, and this indeed is the accepted
origin according to the Oxford English Dictionary,
he does not actually appear to be the originator
of the idea.
There is one known earlier reference to this
figurative sense, which at least my edition
of the OED seems to ignore.
This was spoken during a Parliamentary session
on March 20, 1782, later published in the
1786 Beauties of the British Senate,
Though I have not the honour of being one
of those sagacious country gentlemen, who
have so long vociferated for the American
war, who have so long run on the red-herring
scent of American taxation before they found
out there was no game on foot; they who, like
their prototype, Don Quixote, have mistaken
the barber’s basin for a golden helmet…
Despite this early instance, the expression
didn’t ultimately became part of common
vernacular until after Cobbett reprinted an
“extended repetition
of it in 1833,